yesterday the country faced another
terrible act of violence as we move
forward together as a nation we are
confronted by a familiar partisan debate
not even 24 hours later these heartless
liberals deployed their most sinister
and nefarious despicable weapon talking
with preventable carnage this epidemic
of gun violence in our country is not
preordained it is preventable this body
and four and a half years has done
absolutely nothing enough is enough we
have to have a conversation about how to
stop gun violence in America and we need
to have that conversation right now
no it's not a great time for me I'm in
the middle of doing a TV show maybe we
could table this for ever but they won't
let us everyone from the left is already
coming out opinions blazing taking a
ferocious stand on gun control and if
you're like me a lover of the Second
Amendment you know that the period
directly following a mass shooting is
the most dangerous time for our guns
there's only one thing for us brave
patriotic Americans to do stand our
ground turn and run away from this
debate it's time we all became Gun
Runners because the best way to win an
argument is to run and never have it in
the first place it's right here in the
playbook this is your how-to guide for
how to avoid the gun debate in times of
crisis don't tell your snowflake friends
about this beauty this is a sacred text
that stretches back hundreds of years to
the 1970s when the NRA
the NRA began shifting the gun debate
from a hunting issue to a self-defense
issue and thanks to brave Gun defenders
like Rush and Hannity and that one
cousin that you never visit we have been
adding tactics to it ever since
basically this manual has perfected how
to shut down any gun control talk the
same way we perfected other American
traditions like fireworks and tube meets
so when you're face-to-face with an
uncomfortable debate over guns here are
the moves you need number one not the
time everyone has heard this one because
it's the first line of defense against a
well-regulated dialogue listen I think
that we can have those policy
conversations but today is not that day
I just don't think that that's an
appropriate time for this to be
happening it's just not the time to dive
into the politics and try to score
political points
it's a premature to be discussing
legislative solutions we can have that
discussion at another time this is not
the moment for that day to play politics
it's inappropriate to address issues in
the moment that's why I put sunscreen on
after I'm burnt how else am I supposed
to know where I needed it
the beauty of this argument is that it's
always valid according to the failing
new york times in the last four hundred
and seventy seven days there have been
521 mass shootings in america which is
obviously phony math because how can you
have more shootings than there are days
if that were true we'd be insane not to
do anything about it the point is the
point is pretty much every day in
america is not the time to talk about
gun control and if someone tries to make
it the time just cut to commercial like
this pro you know you're not in favor of
having people who have weapons and
that's after all how the country started
we're a long way away from that second
amendment Katich we said that thank you
to our own we have to step up against a
heartbreak apologies tom robot sorry
they're revenue higher because we had it
we got it got a hard break coming up but
listen this debate will not will not end
now perfectly played perfectly played
megan i don't think you can only cut to
commercial if you're on TV i end a lot
of arguments at home that exact same way
tactic number two pivot see it's easy to
get caught up in the horrific nature of
gun violence but with momentous cases
coming up for the supreme court we need
to think about the balance of power in
our judicial system see what I did there
I pivoted and I pivoted hard where did I
get this technique I learned it from the
best
Jay Waters people help strangers to
safety and law enforcement was running
towards the bullets so all those
kneelers in the NFL out there they need
to recognize when they're kneeling
during the anthem they're kneeling and
we're supposed to be honoring law
enforcement law enforcement that's
trying to save lives not take lives
covering up a real human emotion with
talk of football who is this guy my dad
I wish number three all or nothing
people are going to propose ways to fix
part of the problem but there's no cure
for all of it at once and that's
something we can take advantage of I've
always believed that bad people will get
guns evil people will find the kind of
guns that they want because there's a
huge black market out there
retired Captain Crunch is right bad guys
will always get guns so why bother
trying to stop them attempting to make
any progress is a recipe for failure
which is why I ride a horse to work and
don't trust penicillin step 4
weaponize fear we need to equate any
discussion of gun control with taking
away guns completely because that's what
they're gonna do and we can use that
fear is a weapon like an invisible gun
which fingers crossed is only a few
years away this tactic is terrifying Lee
good at driving our base just watch our
commander-in-chief use it on the
campaign trail Hillary Clinton
so she says the solution is to ban guns
she wants to take away Americans guns
and then admit the very people who want
to slaughter us oh listen to that oh
that man plays fear like a musical
genius
he's like the Kid Rock of fear and
recently the right has found new angles
on this step this thing is jammed with
brand new pages look at this thing most
of them are scribbled in crayon
for example Infowars claims the shooting
was a deep state false flag engineered
by the government to take our guns and
then all of a sudden American voila
people are hoarding Glocks like a kid in
a candy store that has a sale on Glocks
in fact every time there is a major mass
shooting gun sales go up after
yesterday's tragedy shares of sturm
ruger and American Outdoor brands rose
more than 3% because fear sells it's
like sex but slightly less scary
oK you've got all the place and you know
the move so let's huddle up team we've
trained for this moment the next time
someone comes up to you on the street
and tries to start a meaningful
discussion that moves this country
forward
don't let them together we cannot talk
about gun control let's hear it closed
eyes scared hearts can't lose
Oh music to my ears